foreign
[Music]
and welcome to today's webinar practical
considerations for fluorescent cell
staining and microscopy in cancer cell
biology research I'm Shelley Mulock of
lab roots and I'll be your moderator for
today's event today's educational web
seminar is presented by labroots and
brought to you by Thermo Fisher
Scientific to learn more visit
thermofisher.com
we encourage you to participate today by
submitting any questions you may have
during the presentation to do so simply
type them into the ask a question box
and click Send we'll answer as many
questions as we have time for at the end
of the presentation
you may also submit any technical issues
here as well if you have trouble seeing
or hearing the presentation
I'd like to now welcome our speaker Dr
Daniel Beacham Daniel Beacham is a
senior staff staff scientist in the
biology Discovery biology group at the
molecular probes Campus of Thermo Fisher
Scientific in Eugene Oregon for a
complete biography of today's speaker
click their name in the presenters
window at the top right of your screen
Dr Beacham you may now begin your
presentation
thanks Shelly and thanks everyone for
tuning in uh good morning good afternoon
around the world and I'm really thrilled
to uh to join you from uh let's see here
at the late in the evening over here on
the West Coast in uh in Northwest
America uh Eugene Oregon at the Legacy
molecular probes Campus of Thermo Fisher
Scientific
so um as Shelly mentioned I'm going to
give an overview of some of the the
Practical aspects of of fluorescent
Imaging and um and using your microscope
for staining cells visualizing processes
in this case uh as as relevant related
to cancer but also in a more broad sense
to cell biology research so
um here at the molecular probes campus
uh this is our Legacy has is and remains
uh fluorescence Imaging uh many of our
of our foundational tools come from
small molecule dyes synthesized by um
really at a large family of chemists and
uh and with the growth that we've
enjoyed under Thermo Fisher we now have
a fully built team of biologists uh
working together with the chemists to
develop dies that together populate a a
large portfolio our portfolio dates back
decades really to the origins of the
very first fluorescent dyes
commercialized for research use and um
and can now be found online this volume
is is still up to date and um
you'll find a great deal more that I can
cover in our seminar here
so today I'm going to talk about
um as I mentioned some some basic
approaches for fluorescence labeling
I'll I'll give an overview about the use
of structural tools and functional tools
again using cancer cell biology but also
other other cellular processes
that leverage uh you know the activities
of cells and uh and I'll follow you know
that with with some some applications
work sprinkled in there uh either you
know some excerpts from papers or or
case studies we've carried out here
uh some of the considerations I'll I'll
review with you are the different types
of fluorescent probes as I mentioned uh
structural and functional probes as well
as we'll discuss fluorescent proteins
and
um
other targeting strategies for our dies
and um and then also a little bit on on
the use of fluorescent probes in
three-dimensional cultures
so here on the next slide this is the
this is really the big the beginning of
the why of the question why use
fluorescence microscopy and that's uh
right here in the very top on the top
left you can see looking at the
transmitted light of some cells and
culture you see very little there's
there's no cut there's nothing there's
very little to see and so we use
fluorescence to impose contrast onto an
otherwise featureless specimen so on the
left in a transmitted light you can see
oh maybe there's some cells there uh
there's the white light we'll we'll
scatter a little bit around the nucleus
and the edges of the cell but when we
stay in specific structures in the cells
then we get that a much more complete
picture we see the the the footprint of
the cell and we can see the organelles
inside and how they change either in
their spatial distribution maybe how
they redistribute over time and how they
they they can co-localize or or move
together or apart from each other with
the treatment
and so to that end as I mentioned our
Legacy here is historically been a small
molecule fluorescent dyes across the
Spectrum
um that that are engineered either to be
used with live cells or compatible with
fixation
um we have made a great deal of progress
uh over the years and in improving the
performance of the classic fluorescent
dyes you can see at the top the coumarin
and fluorescein to make them more
photostabile and uh and and amenable to
to targeting so uh we we achieved this
in a variety of strategies I'll discuss
uh we also have dies that that report
activity so guys that that either report
the flux of ions the membrane voltage
the activity of enzymes the presence and
absence of oxygen and reactive oxygen
species I'll touch on some of these as
well
I'll also touch on our our development
of a fluorescent protein toolbox uh
We've we've got a very convenient way
that we've been able to build out to to
develop a means to rapidly Express and
follow organelles labeled with
fluorescent proteins and a final
category here are are the fluorescent
Quantum dots which I won't discuss in
this seminar but also have a variety of
of their own very unique uses often as
antibody conjugates in either in Vivo
Imaging and sometimes even electron
microscopy
so the basic steps of a fluorescence
Imaging experiment begin the same that
any other experiment does you you know
you you plan out what you expect to do
um and you you really you know the
things to keep in mind uh either have to
do with the use of dyes for live cells
or fixed cells that's sort of the first
decision you might want to come to and
then
um as with any experiment the the
quality of the data is is going to be
very dependent on the quality of the
sample so of course you know these one
you you generally want to use cells that
are as close to their native state or
close to the state that you want them
when you prepare for Imaging and um so
you know good culture conditions and and
handling and so forth uh we'll figure
into this
now this is this is the the the the
steps three and four are really the most
important for for you know purpose of
our talk today so I'll discuss quite a
bit about the ways you can label cells
so labeling is a very general term but
um in in uh overall you know with their
their steps that you'd want to take to
either titrate the the concentration of
the of the dye the time that it
incubates with the cells and and this is
also where you have a careful selection
of of the dies that you put on the cell
um as I mentioned you want to optimize
the label we all everything that that
we've have produced here and and uh and
developed comes with a great deal of
development effort uh Upstream where
we've done a lot of optimization for you
but uh we always recommend ranges of
concentration to to test uh because that
can change depending on what the cells
are what the microscope that you're
using is or what the time
um time that you're measuring
and then of course the Imaging step
um this is also something supported in a
you know an an entirely other seminar uh
perhaps where we discuss our Imaging
hardware and I'll discuss a couple of
different modalities of Imaging Hardware
that that we uh have here at Thermo
Fisher but you know these these these
rules apply to all fluorescence Imaging
experiments
so um in in planning a fluorescence
Imaging experiment uh you know again as
I mentioned the advantages and the
reasons you use fluorescence Imaging are
to impose contrast
um and you're also permitted uh for many
of our dies to visualize processes as
they happen Dynamic processes in
changing in time either by visualizing
the the
the movement of of molecules uh interest
inside the cell may be structures
reorganizing
and uh in some cases uh we have dyes
that allow you to label an entire cell
and watch it moving inside of a
population or observe interactions
between the cells uh other advantages
are of course just the the ability to
measure
cellular structures in Vivo and living
cells or to fix them in time and analyze
them more closely with with a
multiplexed dies uh to to interrogate a
variety of activities
some of the important considerations in
using dies to label your cells are the
the ability to specifically label so
hopefully we've taken care of that a
fair amount for you but some cells are
very sensitive so you may need to
titrate and find an Optimum
concentration that that will prevent
cytotoxicity
you have to think of how um how the
sample moves living cells are constantly
moving minute to minute even and even
second to Second for looking at some of
the organelles and this is an important
consideration for capturing either time
lapse or expecting the sample to look
the same at Time Zero or Time 5 or 10 or
30 minutes
the organelles will often reorganize
just on their own
there's another important consideration
um people often overlook this that
autofocus and light itself in the end in
the absence of dye uh this is is toxic
to cells especially short wavelength
light high energy light in the UV and
and blue part of the spectrum carries a
lot of energy and and can in fact
um pose uh challenges to cells and
induce some of the processes I'll
describe later on apoptosis and reactive
oxygen species and and to that end we
try to design our diets having longer
wavelengths to avoid uh that that
Illumination in those high energy and
harmful wavelengths and so you want to
be mindful of how much light you're
actually exposing to the cells because
even without the dye
um illuminating your cells with plain
polarized high energy light can be toxic
in itself
and last is is just the need
particularly for live cells for for
keeping them in as as happy a
physiological State as possible
so I'm going to now kind of switch gears
to the description of dies and
genetically encoded structures uh
genetically encoded tools that we've
we've built to look at cellular
structures in uh in situ and this is uh
this is important for cancer research
for a variety of reasons mostly to
understand how cells are behaving at a
baseline State and then how they change
with either the induction of a of a of a
gene or the addition of a of a drug and
so uh and as of course many Cancer drugs
are are Target the cytoskeleton so uh
I'll be I'll be describing some of these
in detail
and these these of course can be
addressed in uh as I as I've shown here
with with our our fluorescent dyes that
that are either conjugated to a toxin or
in fact engineered to uh to bind to
specific structures
uh I describe I'll I'll go on a bit more
about genetically encoded sensors that
that are targeted in the Cell by a gene
delivery method that we uh are very
happy with here it's a bit of a novel
expression method but this is also
permits live live cell and fixable
staining and then a third category over
here is is just the simple staining of
of the sample with antibodies uh that
are targeted to structures and molecules
in the cell that is and this this is
entirely relegated to fixed cell samples
that are fixed with formaldehyde and
often permeabilized with with uh
detergents and then probed with a
cocktail of antibodies and fluorophores
so
um as I mentioned the fluorescent you
know probes themselves are are just the
small molecule versions are are very
easy to use uh they're they're usually a
single vial that you just dilute onto
the sample uh you have the advantage of
uniform labeling and they can in fact be
comes they can become reporters
themselves uh of activity for instance
as the cytoskeleton rearranges
you want to be mindful of the amount
that that you use so again a titration
Step At the beginning and you need to be
mindful of uh off off Target staining so
too much you know more signal also means
more noise so you need to be mindful of
the background and off-target staining
that can happen at high concentrations
and you need to be careful about uh
putting too many dies together uh or
else they will begin to bleed through to
each other's channels
and uh last note here is is also a
little bit more cancer relevant and
that's the uh I'll show one clear
example of where a die actually affects
the cell cycle uh and or promotes
cytotoxicity and low concentrations are
needed to produce the the effect and so
as I mentioned uh these structural and
functional considerations of cells are
important in cancer uh largely just
simply to understand either cell cycle
control I've got specific examples here
we've got some descriptions of
post-transcriptional Regulation tools as
well as sort of more more signaling and
metabolic stress responses from from
from the stimuli and as I'll go on here
uh for the study of structure
and we like to use this uh kind of a
cartoon as a as a way to to highlight
some of the some of the things we're
going to talk about and so if you think
of of cell Health
um from this from the birth of a healthy
cell through uh stimuli that produce a
variety of stress changes through either
the induction of death and and even
after death uh the things that happen to
cell cells
um these all of course are part of
normal cell function that can become
perturbed in cancer and so what I've got
here are a number of sort of waypoints
that that we like to to address uh with
that that we've developed either tools
or identified you know needs uh in the
research Community for means to
recognize healthy viable cells recognize
the activation of of protection
mechanisms intrinsic to healthy cells
and then uh along the way say this if
you just again considering our cell
Health uh uh Continuum here uh the
activity of pre-lethal stressors like
mitochondrial toxins
drugs that affect the cytoskeleton cell
cycle Inhibitors
um and then the outcomes of those either
by the activation of caspase damage of
DNA
Downstream loss of plasma membrane
integrity and ultimately the the
phagocytosis of the dead cells
themselves
so uh looking just early in this in this
in this Continuum as I mentioned
structural tools to look at just the
morphology healthy cells have a known
and
reliable morphology
and our addressable dyes show you this
uh very clearly by uh in this case
conjugating them to a toxin so falloidin
is a mushroom toxin that recognizes the
filamentous actin in cells it doesn't
bind to free actin it recommends it
recognizes filamentous actin and you're
able to visualize it in fixed cells that
have been permealized by conjugating to
our dyes so here's a nice example of a
of a die conjugated to the mushroom
Toxin phylloidin and the visualization
in in cells another class of dye that I
mentioned are dyes that are engineered
to recognize a specific binding site in
the cell for instance dappy which
recognizes and binds to the minor Groove
in uh in double-stranded DNA and that
allows you to visualize the nucleus
which becomes a very critical uh point
for orienting yourself in the cell in
many many cases
so um I Philip F Acton can be uh
conjugated to dice as I mentioned and
then you can um it can be easily
multiplexed with with other uh
landmarking tools so in this case
um fluorescent proteins that are fused
to Talen which uh which lives along the
actin microtubules and and at the ends
or tips mitochondria which of course are
distributed throughout the cell that are
labeled with the red fluorescent protein
or um the nucleus which is again stained
in blue
the fluid and conjugates and our
secondary antibodies have have gotten a
recent upgrade with the Alexa floor plus
dies this has been the effort of a great
deal of research uh in recent years to
improve the photo stability and
brightness of our dies and so here and
there in the catalog you'll see this
designation of plus uh indicating that
um the their their they have bright
brighter signal and photo stability than
the Legacy dye they came from
so here's a nice time lapse um Now using
a different tool using tubulin tubulin
tracker so this is a a tool that's
compatible a die that's compatible with
live cells it it binds to uh to tubulin
as it's forming and what I'm in uh what
I'm showing in the video that's playing
is are some cells dividing where the
nucleus is stained in red and uh the
tubulin is stained with the Deep Red
tubulin tracker probe
and tubulin has uh the the tubulin
tracker deep red has a far Red Spectrum
uh so-called far red it's it excites
with 647 laser or works in the Sci-Fi
filter Cube and that means that it takes
it it's those are nice low energy uh
wavelengths to excite cells it labels
cells quickly and gives a a very
characteristic you know staining pattern
uh following the the cytoskeleton of the
tubulin cytoskeleton
and so um in development of it one of
the things we wanted to make sure is
that it didn't alter the normal function
of cells so on the left
um we we've actually labeled neurons in
a neuronal culture uh and visualize them
over several days so this time lapse is
is in a confocal microscope looking at a
at a slice of the cells where the dye
stays on for I think this is if I can
see the bottom there it's it's many
several uh sorry that looks like 65 or
70 hours
um in a time lapse and uh so you can see
the tubulin uh you know moving around
and this the cells of course staying
healthy during the duration
on the right
is an example of uh over labeling cells
so for instance if you if you think you
want to have a brighter label and use
more dye what you see on the left uh or
sorry the middle panel are some Hela
cells labeled with the tubulin tracker
that are over labeled and they don't
divide they actually they they freeze in
the middle of of mitosis and the signal
just kind of goes away whereas if you
use less dye you you have far far less
impact on the physiology of the cell and
you can watch cells divide through
several Cycles without perturbing their
function
so um this is just a made to be a lesson
to highlight the importance of titrating
your your dies and and optimizing the
labeling condition
including the the light intensity and
the intervals of of visualization
I'll switch now to uh to targeted
fluorescent protein fusions this is
another form of fluorescence of course
that we brought these these uh these
these tools on board oh almost 10 years
ago now uh just by reviewing the
literature of Jennifer Lippincott
Schwartz and using uh the the targeting
sequences uh that that that that that
send proteins to specific parts of the
cell so it's for instance the actin
cytoskeleton free fluorescent proteins
and the cytoplasm the endoplasmic
reticulum and so on this list uh to the
right uh in gfp and RFP represents uh a
good number I think most of the
fluorescent proteins that we've packaged
and the way we've packaged them is in a
is in a a very unique system that is
very cell friendly as we call the call
this expression system the back mem
system and so what it allows us to do is
to package fluorescent protein sequence
into a non-replicating bacular virus a
modified bacula virus that has been
engineered to work in mammalian cells
and the way it works is this the bacula
virus can of course is is replicated in
insect cells with the polyhedron
promoters and and that's fine for making
macular virus but in our case we have
pseudotyped the baculovirus with the
vsvg pseudopro pseudotype coat protein
and where it allows it to bind and enter
mammalian cells where the enhanced um
where the CMV promoter driving the gene
of your interest is recognized in the
mammalian cells so the mammalian cell
ignores the polyhedron promoters of the
virus and only expresses the gene
product of your of your Gene of Interest
which is also got a wpre enhancement RNA
export and stability element and this
provides rapid and efficient expression
of the of the protein of your choice in
a in a very portable way so uh We've
made we've made these for you and you
just simply buy
um and use these these products straight
off of the Shelf without having to grow
the viruses they're also only a P2
containment so they can be used on the
bench top and handled regularly like
like any other product or any other
reagent
so here are two anti-cancer drugs the
trunculine and cytokines used to perturb
either the the tubule the microtubulin
sorry microtubule or actin cytoskeleton
uh so you know we've we've got the
fusion of the the of the tubulin uh in
gfp and the actin labeled in RFP with a
reference dye in the nucleus to report
where then where the uh the DNA is
um with our with a with a Hurst or dappy
type die
and so again these are live cell time
lapse videos just showing that that as
the trunculine breaks down the the
tubulin cytoskeleton and cytoklase and
breaks the actin cytoskeleton down
these these
um these are two examples of of using
the structure of of the cells these
structural cytoskeleton elements to
visualize uh the activity of a drug
and I'm sorry that's a there these are
bsl1 products not bsl2 that's that's my
mistake
um the other and the last note on on the
back ma'am reagents is that they're uh
very as I mentioned they're they're
widely uh they'll have tropism across a
wide variety of cell types including
many primary cells uh so I won't review
them all here but uh they're very well
tolerated in many cell types
um here's a series of structural dies
that we've put together in a cocktail uh
following the literature of Ann
Carpenter at the broad Institute so um
this is a a procedure called cell
painting and it make makes use of of
specific dyes targeted to the cell
nucleus uh that dice that Target RNA
inside the nucleus and cytoplasm dyes
that Target the endoplasmic reticulum
the plasma membrane and Golgi the
cytoskeleton and mitochondria and and in
multiplexing these six spectrally
distinct dyes what you can get is the
the sort of the fingerprint of of a of a
happy uh healthy cell and then what you
can do is drug the cell and look at the
change of of these six elements
um in response to the Baseline so either
they they change in spatial orientation
to each other or they change in
brightness as they're up or down
regulated or perturbed in the context of
your experiment and so what this gives
you is kind of a
a really a broad phenotyping fingerprint
that looks at many aspects of the cell's
function at once I will point out this
is largely a tool used for high content
Imaging and I'll discuss a little bit
about that later on these are using an
automated microscope with with multiple
channels to quickly discriminate and
segment these individual elements and
capture them and analyze their their
movements with with machine learning
algorithms that will
basically give you tractable results
that I'll discuss a bit later the six of
these the guide dies together in
traditional microscopy would are become
difficult to deconvolve and so I do want
to highlight these are this is a high
content tool but you can use the
individual elements of course alone
okay another Hallmark of of cell health
is uh the the
proliferation and proliferative capacity
of cells and this is a big one for
cancer research as well so healthy cells
divide and
um and uh and and and then you know
perturbations to the cell cycle show up
as either changes in the number of the
rate of of proliferation or just in many
cases just the number of living cells
um this is the probably the most
effective way that we've deployed this
technology called click chemistry
um we actually were the first to
commercialize uh and license click
chemistry back in oh gosh I want to say
it was 2006 or seven that we began work
on click chemistry and this to build the
system that I'm about to describe to you
but of course click chemistry was made
famous just last year uh when the
inventors won the Nobel Prize for the
development of this tool set and the
reason we like click chemistry is that
it is entirely bio orthogonal it that
this is the name given to the Copper
catalyzed cycloaddition of an azide over
there and the left the letter A to an
alkyne here on the right and letter b
and that produces a conjugated protein
sorry a conjugated structure that can be
tagged onto proteins and it's a it's a
way to to quickly mix and match uh
targets with labels is the way that
we've used it but it also is used to to
generate you know specific binding sites
on antibodies for drugs and antibody
drug conjugates you know many many uses
it's very small so much smaller than the
streptavidin and and antibodies or even
fluorescent proteins and
um we have
excellent control of the specificity uh
with click chemistry and very low
backgrounds owing to the fact that there
are no endogenous azines or alkynes in
the sample
so to visualize proliferation with click
chemistry you use a metabolic
incorporation strategy historically this
was done with brominated deoxyridine
which is incorporated into dividing
cells at the at the regular intervals
wherever a thymidine would go you a
brominated deoxyridine is introduced and
then the cells can be fixed and
permeabilized and some some treatments
they have to do in actually an acid
treatment and a fair amount of
permeabilization to make the brominated
deoxyridine accessible to a fluorescent
labeled antibody
so a specific antibody for brdu will
then show you cells with newly
synthesized DNA
we've sidestep a lot of the um did the
detection step with that by using a much
smaller handle the the ethanyl
deoxyridine over here on the right so
this is our strategy with using click
chemistry to detect newly synthesized
DNA so edu is Incorporated in into newly
synthesized DNA and then it's detected
in a single step with the azide
complement of the dye
and so what that looks like is and so
and of course the reason that that is
helpful is is that you be by using just
a single step you have a much uh you
have much cleaner tissue architecture
you have preservation of the cellular
structures that you can see here
um with with the uh tubulin uh stained
in blue and mitochondria
um uh stained here stained here in uh in
in green but the the newly divided cells
uh show these red nuclei where the where
the clickable ethanyl deoxyridine has
has a has appeared
and in fact people feed ethanyl
deoxyridine to animals and then can
follow up and and visualize in situ uh
and tissue slices to see where newly
born cells are uh either uh with with
high frequency of occurrence like the
gut or were they in places where cells
divide more rarely like the brain
and uh of course you know as you can
imagine proliferation is is used to
interrogate the activity of drugs uh so
for instance in this one the topicide uh
no a well-known uh toxin used in in
cancer research uh here showing a dose
dependent you know effect
um on cells over in a 24-hour treatment
with a high concentration to the left
and the number of of freshly divided
cells tapering off uh over at the far
end and high concentration of the drug
and increasing a number uh to the right
at low concentration
in coupling this with the high content
instrumentation uh in this case the CX-7
laser
platform the um uh you can then estimate
the the percent the percent of the cells
that have recently divided and look at
the titration of of of that cell number
in a in a in a Quantified uh recording
uh with with with the cell count on the
y-axis and uh and quickly determine the
activity of of a drug in in how it in in
its activity on proliferation
um I'll leave off one more uh discussion
of Click chemistry looking at RNA uh
that's another of course aspect of a
healthy cell division and so the same
approach that we've used to visualize
nascent DNA nascent newly synthesized
DNA can also be used to visualize RNA
and this is just in instead of uh
instead of ethanyl deoxyridine we have
ethanyl uridine so this is incorporated
into newly synthesized RNA and detected
in a single step with click chemistry
as you can imagine click is very
versatile and the click in itself would
be many different seminars that I could
cover on DNA RNA protein and
post-translational modifications but
here I've just touched on proliferation
um also in the spirit of visualizing RNA
we have a a very highly evolved
immunocyte immunocyto immunochemistry
application with our view RNA tool set
this allows you to actually visualize
individual copies of of rnas in cells
and look carefully at their spatial
distribution
with a strategy designed to recognize
the RNA with specific probes that are
made in a custom uh in a custom assay
and then detected with branched DNA
attached to many fluorophores providing
an amplification step for up to four
transcripts that can be detected
simultaneously
I'll point out also that our system has
the advantage of a very fast and
collapsed workflow
which again keeps cell structures intact
and is compatible with antibody staining
uh and further Multiplex if you want to
see more things besides the RNA and the
cell
I've put in a couple of examples of use
in the literature just quickly to
highlight you know people use this assay
to either visualize the translocation of
a message of an RNA or just The
Disappearance of it in response to a
drug treatment so here nucleosamide and
triphosin are are used to induce the
translocation of a of a Target either
stained with an antibody and
localized in copy with the uh with the
um um a view RNA kit that the bars in
red show a control treatment these are
essentially fixed cells uh showing that
the of course the RNA is not
Incorporated and no change is detected
um but we can see a knockdown or or
translocation of the signal uh with the
treatments of the drugs
um okay I'm going to switch to some fun
stuff this is much more my wheelhouse
and a place where I have spent a good
deal of my personal time I'm still very
much a bench scientist here at the
campus and I I work on uh functional
probes I I um as with my training in
neurosciences has a lot of focus on ION
sensors and voltage but we also develop
probes to visualize other activities and
cells and it's in this case the next
several are looking at the reactive
oxygen species produced by healthy cells
um healthy and and that's that's that's
so both healthy cells and stress cells
produce reactive oxygen species and what
can sometimes happen is the cell loses
its ability to buffer reactive oxygen
species or a drug will induce the
overproduction of reactive oxygen
species but
um in in this in both cases these are
both good
um mechanisms these are both these these
represent a tool a class of tools that
can be very helpful in identifying
mechanism of action in a in a in a
either a toxin treatment or or trying to
understand how a gene has altered the
metabolism of a cell
um particularly with a mitochondrial
phenotype
people have used
um our our classic dyes to study
reactive oxygen species for many years
the reduced fluorescein dies suffer from
the inability to use them in complete
media and they photo bleach very quickly
these cell rocks deep red dyes are and
and now newer green and orange forms
recognize reactive oxygen species and
can be uh uh fixed and have a very
photostable
um reporting activity to a wide variety
of Ros species that can be found in a
table
that I won't describe here
uh the nice thing about them though is
uh yeah they they work on both live and
fixed cells so you can actually
visualize the the activity of the die in
this case uh in Multiplex with a
mitochondrial membrane and uh indicator
so tmrm is a mitochondrial dye that that
stains healthy mitochondria
um it shows up bright red at the
beginning of the recording and then uh
the reactive oxygen dye is in fact a
nuclear binding dye that that binds to
DNA upon oxidation so uh the dye is dark
until it is oxidized and then it's
permitted to move to the nucleus and
bind DNA and produce a very
um very localized and bright signal in
response to reactive oxygen species so
you see that the mitochondria are
becoming dimmer with the menadion
treatment and the Ros signal is coming
up in uh in time
next couple of slides are on another
very important pathway in cell biology
and particularly cancer research and
that's the activation of caspase enzymes
to induce DNA I'm sorry to induce cell
death so program cell death is is a
well-known phenomenon and the main
executioner of program cell death is
caspase three seven
um caspase three seven
uh induces uh ultimately cell death by
by just the non-speci not non-specific
by by cleaving cells at a specific uh
site in their protein sequence using
recognizing the devd target sequence
um and so what our strategy in
developing a caspase sensor was is
taking the devd caspase recognition
sequence and fusing it to a DNA binding
die much like I just showed you of the
DNA binding die that binds only after
oxidation this is now a Dye that can
only bind after cleavage by caspase so
at rest the dye is dark and cannot see
anything but when you induce caspase in
this case with the activation by
sterosporine or another
toxin drug the dye is cleaved away from
the devd can translocate to the nucleus
and produce a fluorogenic signal
the nice thing about here is that these
are there's actually a lot of advantages
that you don't have to wash the cells or
remove the dye or the media for it to
work the sample can be fixed and and
counted afterward permeabilized and
stained with other things
and you get a lot of amplification of
the signal so every caspase enzyme stays
active and it keeps cleaving dye as long
as it's around
so um I um back to the now shall just
show this video one more time this shows
uh again that a multiplex experiment
where we're watching the mitochondrial
membrane potential in red
disappearing Upstream of the activation
of caspase as you would expect in
temporal sequence
we've recently developed a gfp form of
this die so it's also a caspase 37
sensor that is now operating in the red
far red Channel and this can be easily
multiplexed now with the green
fluorescent protein or deep red dyes for
cell death or the the nucleus in blue so
further just in increasing the multiplex
capabilities of of the of the system
see if I can go to the next slide oh and
this just shows another video of this uh
of the caspase red in action so now
we've we've got a different live cell
stain the calcium green so healthy
living cells uh
will will stain brightly with calcium am
Ester which accumulates inside and is
maintained there and then upon treatment
you see The Disappearance of the green
signal
and the appearance of the red apotodic
nuclei from the from the caspase red
version of the uh the 37 caspase 37
sensor
um I think our last application with
caspase or second to last here uh is
just another demonstration that of
course
um You can count the cells uh in high
content so you can look at the
percentage of the of the cells that are
cast based positive either at different
drug concentrations or different time
points and quickly
export that data in in graphic fashion
with um with our high content automated
analysis
and as another caspase Multiplex this
just highlights the the appearance of of
reactive oxygen and the appearance of
caspase signal
um UPS you know uh in in temporarily in
time so uh with Star Wars boring you see
a rapid induction of of reactive oxygen
followed by a later induction of caspase
three seven
so here's another uh another example
taken from the literature where
uh researchers have taken the
mitochondrial die that I mentioned so
mitochondrial dyes like tetramethyl
rhodamine methyl Ester the tmrm or in
this one the Mito tracker orange dye
these dyes uh stain healthy mitochondria
based on the membrane potential of the
mitochondria so they accumulate and
stain brightly in in healthy cells with
with highly polarized mitochondria and
then they demonstrate the activity of
the the drug quercetin
as it decreases the mitochondrial
membrane potential you see drop in the
signal from TM uh from Mito tracker
orange on the right and then you also
see the appearance of cell death uh over
on the left in with the cytox green dye
cytoks green and dies in that family
don't stain live cells they're they're
they they're they're unable to enter
live cells with intact membranes and can
only enter cells and stain the the
nucleus after uh the membrane has broken
down in permitted entries so you can see
an increase in cell permeability and
consequent cell death uh parallel with a
decrease in mitochondrial membrane
potential
the dies that we use to label cells are
are often called trackers and these
these get used in measurements of uh
they're often just used to follow cells
in proliferation uh but here we also
like to use them to follow motility
so um on the left is you know an
angiogenesis assay uh which is is you
know one of the consequences of of the
tumor growth and on the right is a live
cell uh version of a something like a
wound healing assay where you can
visualize cell mobility in Us in an
artificially induced scratch visual
visualized in live cell time lapse
microscopy on the right
and um
so this cell tracker deep red dye is
going to appear several more times uh it
either can be used to label cells that
are used to induce activity in this case
we have a cancer spheroids that are over
here on the left stained with the
caspase die showing the basal level of
of of of
of
apoptosis and then uh when they're
co-local in that when they're
co-incubated with activated T cells you
see an increase in apoptosis or if the T
cells are not activated then you see
less apoptosis and that can be
Quantified of course as well in high
content Imaging
um one other application also
multiplexing the Mido track cell tracker
deep red
feeding the natural killer T cells uh to
to uh uh
skbr3 spheroid 3D culture where uh the
cell event caspase green is is somewhat
activated by by natural killer cells in
the absence of trastuzumab
um antibody and uh herceptin that is and
uh or greatly increase in the presence
of of the antibody which increases the
recognition and killing potential of the
natural killer cells
these things as I mentioned you know 3D
cultures uh are
obviously very popular and and have a
lot of relevance to tumor biology and so
you can uh take take individual assays
like the ones I described the the
induction of caspase uh green and the
decrease in signal from Mido tracker
orange and visualize dose response to a
drug as as higher concentrations of
nucleosamide you see a loss in
mitochondrial signal and a gain in the
in the caspase signal in two different
cell types
um I'll I'll spend a bit of time here
now uh on the visualization of of
internalizing processes
um uh either phagocytosis or or
trafficking of of membrane targets which
are both
um relevant in in cancer Therapies
um so just this is just meant to
describe the strategy these are dyes
that are pH sensitive that are dark at
neutral pH and become brighter as they
are acidified so when the dyes are
conjugated in this case do bacteria or
other cells then they can be fed to
macrophages and you you see the the
signal up here over time as they bind to
the outside and are transported in
you can also conjugate Frodo pH
sensitive dyes to to targets outside of
cells like in this case the low density
lipoprotein or two antibodies
so our antibodies of course are are as
known or known as much as being
Therapeutics as they are for our own
bodies uh helpful function and so
labeling antibodies and making them pH
sensitive gives people the means to
visualize where the antibody is going in
the cell uh so in this case you can
visualize the location of a labeled
antibody in the lysosome where it is
co-localized with the cell light gfp
lysosomal fluorescent protein lamp and
and then multiplexed with the nucleus
for for landmarking and and once again
our friend the cell mask deep red uh
very versatile dye to show you the
plasma membrane
a new version of of our pH dye that
we're very pleased to uh announce is a
longer wavelength this this is a new die
that works out in the Deep Red Channel
and has uh and one other important
change is we've modified the pH that
activates the diet pH five and this
means that the dye turns on later in the
endosomal pathway and it also means the
dye is darker at neutral pH so we have a
much larger signal to noise and again
measurements of Phagocytosis on the left
as I've shown you or uh you know
antibody directed cellular phagocytosis
of labeled cells on the right
um but the biggest uh I I think the
biggest impact is uh the the ability to
efficiently label uh antibodies uh in
this case uh again uh trust usumab uh
herceptin drugs that are that have the
mechanism of binding to EGF receptors on
the outside of cells and are quickly
translocated inside to the late
endosomes and lysosomes where the dye
fluoresces brightly
so you can see the signal to noise of
neutral of of labeled antibodies that
neutral pH of 7.5 to an acidic pH and
see a very large signal increase owing
to a much smaller background signal at
neutral pH on the lower right
so
um we now have you know what we call
Classic and these new deep red
antibody labeling kits that are are you
know suited to the the either the color
Channel or the PH range of of the user's
interest but uh these all leverage pH
gradients to visualize activity in cells
um and so to that end uh visualizing the
internalization of a frodo-labeled
antibodies in cells you can see the
antibodies are readily internalized in
in in spreads made from cells that
generate the uh EGF receptor and uh and
when the antibody is by itself it's
internalized but when the antibody is is
also labeled with a payload an
anti-cancer drug mmae as is done in the
case of this trastuzumab label then you
see the induction of caspase activity so
you can see the consequence of the
internalization and the cell death that
follows
So to that end as I think we're at time
now I'm gonna spend a minute just
directing you to a a newly built uh and
highly
um uh we've got our web presence has is
always changing and so we've got a a a a
a very uh thorough Cancer Resource
cancer research Resource Center that
goes of course far beyond the scope of
this small presentation I've given here
today across you know immuno oncology to
solid tumor research
we have some great teaching tools uh
over here on the right uh our our
imaging University School of
fluorescence will take you through uh
step-by-step labeling and the detection
strategies along with our Learning
Center and the spectral viewer uh isn't
it is a very important tool in
understanding which dies can be
multiplexed with with each other
and last of all I want to take a moment
um to speak to our antibodies I got to
speak to antibody labeling and um and
some of our our newer um uh approaches
there uh but our our antibody catalog is
has now been completely reinvented with
um a lot of our own applications data as
well as validations from the literature
so the the search for validated
antibodies is much easier uh with a a
tool that we generated so I will pause
there I think I'm at time and I'll thank
everyone for their attention this
afternoon uh wherever you are and um I'm
happy to take any questions
I'm going to uh let's see here turn it
back over to my host and uh and look
forward to uh answering your questions
and whatever I can't answer here
um we'll encourage you to reach out
electronically and I'll do my best to
follow up as timely as possible
yeah thank you so much Dan for your
informative presentation we will now
start the live q a portion of the
webinar if you have a question you'd
like to ask please do so now we'll
answer as many of your questions as we
have time for so let's get started our
first question is
um we wish to image ourselves in the
native unperturbed state as possible but
still be able to quantify them for
example counting morphology Etc Midway
in our experiment what would you suggest
okay well so that's sort of back in the
in the early part of my slides where I
was mentioning the importance of happy
and healthy cells some of our some of
our microscopes have onstage incubators
and this allows you to to visualize and
to culture cells long term in the
context of an Imaging experiment
um the selection of dyes is the other uh
important piece and so not all dyes will
be compatible with with live cell
Imaging and it's important to you know
read a little bit about the dyes before
you uh just try to label them and and
expect the cells to behave normally so
um I showed examples of dyes that that
are very that are completely harmless to
cell function like the cell tracker or
the pH sensor dies even the cast-based
eyes you know you're showing the Cell at
the end of its life but it's not
disturbing the cell to make the
measurement the dye can be present for
many days and not affect the cells and
it doesn't activate until the cast basis
is turned on
but
um really the the same rules that apply
to cell culture uh maintaining the the
oxygen and the uh sorry the carbon
dioxide and and the humidity and
temperature
um are all in effect here and so either
on stage incubators or the you know sort
of careful culture of of your cells and
and uh measurement with the appropriate
reagents is is the key to success
thank you so much for that
um our next question is I heard that
dapi has quite a broad spectrum on the
emission and often interfere with other
fluorescent Channel channels is there
any alternative diet for dapi uh they
said like s-y-t-o-x
um without disturbing gfp and RFP
signals yeah if a specific
recommendation there is a guy called
herxed it's difficult to to pronounce
but it's spelled
h-o-e-c-h-s-t Heist and uh this is a
this is a a narrower Spectrum die we
also have a long Spectrum die that's
used in in our uh to to segment nuclei
and high content Imaging called
nucleotracker Deep Red and um this is a
also a a live cell but fixable die that
can be used to preserve the the green
and and and inner red channels uh that
is that's an alternative to dappy
okay there are many nuclear dyes
it sounds like it okay so the next
question is
um for be all analysis which panel is
best how can we use image analysis
software easily
sorry so for for what type of analysis B
uh it says be all so capital B and
capital A L L
we all oh my gosh I'm afraid I don't
know what type of analysis that is
we do have automated
um analysis you know uh
packages that either go with our our
microscopy Suite
um using so I showed examples of the
evos microscope and it has an onboard
analysis package called Celeste
c-e-l-l-e-s-t-e and that's a very
powerful
um sort of smaller scale Imaging
analysis program that that will quickly
automate and quantify imagery and then
our high content Imaging packages use a
much more sophisticated software that
will quickly generate graphic data from
either percent positive cells or even
the trans translocation of signals
within a cell and that's that's um maybe
that's that's that's probably the best
approach to getting a multiplex
um read of up to seven different
channels
okay using high content Imaging
perfect but if if someone follows up
with the bll I'll do my best to
understand but I actually don't
recognize BNL
okay no worries I'll let you know if it
comes through and our next question is
what would be suit a suitable
application for a wholesale labeled die
or labeling die uh why do I see cells
bubbling during live cell Imaging
experiments a suitable application for
for labeling cells like like for
instance I showed several examples with
the cell tracker deep red is either
visualizing their motility so
visualizing as they move around in a in
a population even for tracking them as
they divide so you have one labeled cell
and it divides and then you have two
labeled cells and three and four and the
signal goes down with each division but
that can also be used to quantify how
many cells in in a in a in a population
have recently divided in fact it's done
in flow cytometry but for for
traditional Imaging people label the
membrane of cells just to to give them
contrast and see where they are among
the population so for instance the the
the cell tracker deep red uh cells that
I I was showing you in the organoids
um and and steroids where uh labeled
just to give the camera something to
focus on and then really the activity is
happening in the green Channel
bubbling happens
um often as a result of either
cytotoxicity from overloading with dye
or too much
phototoxicity so light itself can can be
toxic to cells and so you may need to
adjust the uh the intensity and duration
of the exposures of of the of the light
on the cells to avoid phototoxicity but
there are a lot of things that can cause
bubbling and that could also indicate an
osmotic problem with the with the
solution that you're labeling with
um I'd have to see or understand a bit
more
ah thank you okay great
um the next question is how long does
transient expression with cellulite
reagents last or primo sensors that's a
great question um yeah so I described
the back ma'am uh protein expression
system that we've used to to package uh
fluorescent protein and biosensor tools
and um it's a CMV driven promoter and
that means that you see pretty fast
expression and every time the cell is
divide they take half of the copy number
with them so you can expect to see the
onset of expression in six or eight
hours and peaking at about 15 to 16
hours and then it will last for several
days it really depends on the target uh
so some some some proteins are turned
over very quickly the membrane labels
are are you know um they they they're
they're they're always new membrane is
being made and so uh you can either get
long-lived expression by by just
re-transducing with with more of the
with more of the viral uh uh delivery or
or culturing it continuously in the
presence of it but you can count on on
on you know minimum of two days up to
five or six
perfect
our next question
Dan is
with less with less abundant rare Target
and using an antibody validated for ICC
but still can't see my Target and
they're wondering if you have any advice
for them yeah that so I didn't really
get to spend much time on it but uh we
have a couple of strategies for Signal
amplification
so this is now used for for as you
mentioned rare or low copy number
targets
um I think the the most commonly used is
uh using a secondary antibody to detect
your your protein of Interest so you
have the primary antibody which which
which binds to the protein and then you
have either a polyclonal or a pooled
monoclonal
cocktail of of labeled secondary
antibodies to recognize that Target and
each of them will have many dies and
that will provide signal amplification
another strategy for Signal
amplification without the need for
secondary antibodies is a terrorist is
called teramide signal amplification
that uses an enzyme conjugated to the
second and secondary antibody that
produces
um a large number of binding sites for
fluorescent dye called tyramide
conjugated to our Alexa floors and that
will that will produce a high copy
number of of fluorescent targets uh for
in the vicinity of of your target of
Interest so teramide signal
amplification and secondary antibodies
are my two main recommendations for
Signal amplification
Jen so our last question for today is
I've found protocols for probes in 2D
but not for 3D models do you have any
general advice for that yeah we we have
a well it's different for each die and
and now uh with with each of our dies
you'll find
um uh directions to a 3D we actually
have a 3D resource that I probably
should have mentioned in our website
um what you'll often find is that you
know the dies that you use at a lower
concentration and 2D either have to be
increased in concentration or incubated
longer time in 3D
but but not all dice are created equal
when it comes to 3D the penetrance of
the die and the the the the the cell's
ability to tolerate the dye can change
quite a bit in 3D so I showed examples
of well characterized 3D dies uh in the
in the Excel event dies then the some of
our mitochondrial dyes and the uh uh say
for instance the the the the cell
tracker deep red
um but I it really is a case-by-case
basis and and it's it's usually
described in the product sheet for each
die if it's 3D compatible or uh it's
more likely going to be captured in our
in our 3D cultures uh web portal where
there's a great deal more information
relevant to tissues and uh and and uh
multicellular 3D and and organoid
structures
okay oh my goodness thank you so much
Dan uh do you have any final comments
for our audience today
um no just thanks so much for for
spending your your afternoon with us
here and and um we do welcome any any
questions we have an excellent you know
technical support team and whatever they
can't uh answer they send to us in
research and development so I welcome
the chance to to speak with people in
the field as often as I can so I can
better understand uh problems and
develop in in their Direction so
um sometimes we can help out from
research and development as well so we
we look forward to hearing from you and
and thank you again for your time
absolutely awesome okay thank you again
Dr Beacham for your time today and for
your important research uh we'd also
like to thank lab roots and our sponsor
at Thermo Fisher Scientific for
underwriting today's educational webcast
uh before we go I'd like to thank the
audience as well for joining us today
and for their interesting questions uh
questions we did not have time for today
and those submitted during the on-demand
period will be addressed by the speaker
via the contact information you provided
at the time of registration this webcast
can be viewed on demand and lab Roots
will alert you via email when it's
available for replay we encourage you to
share that email with your colleagues
who have missed today's Live Events
until next time goodbye
bye bye thank you